let's get to as we often do on fridays
some stories um that i just sort of ran
out of time for during the week i want
to talk about republican senator cynthia
lummus who represents uh wyoming senator
cynthia lummus spoke the other day at
the commencement of university of
wyoming she gave the graduation speech
and during the graduation speech for
some reason i don't know why
she went in a transphobic direction
injecting into the speech almost like
you would bleach for kovid which is a
bad idea and that was this was also a
bad idea
um the f that people aren't telling the
fundamental truth that there are
only two sexes that anything can be
challenged and in fact
what she said was quite postmodern um in
the sense that
she made the claim that now
there's no empirical realities you can
just sort of challenge anything which is
a postmodern idea at its core so let's
look at the clip and then we'll discuss
now she criticized that i want to be
clear
she didn't make the postmodern argument
she made the argument that sex has
become almost postmodern in that any
opinion about what sex is is equally
valid and whatever okay let's listen
you woke up this morning
with more individual freedom in the most
creative divinely inspired nation on
earth oh and one of the things is the
video is sort of like sped up so i'm
going to turn it down so it's at like
normal speed
the transformations and disruptions i
have alluded to are testing those very
freedoms
beyond watch
there are those in government who
believe
not that the creator endowed us with
inalienable rights as the founders of
our nation acknowledged in the
declaration of independence so by the
way first of all
suggesting that it sort of should be
like the official thing in the united
states that everything we have all the
rights we have came from god which
remember they they love to do this they
love to say
the creators the framers of the
constitution the founding fathers
they believed that rights came from god
or in religion or whatever the case may
be sure they were deists but they
believed it shouldn't have a role in
civil government they'll they'll skip
that part but let's continue that
government created those rights and the
government should redefine those rights
including our rights to freedom of
speech religion property assembly and to
keep and bear arms
even fundamental scientific truths such
as the existence of two sexes male and
female are subject to challenge these
days
[Applause]
and they boo
you know i
[Music]
[Applause]
it's not normal for commencement
speakers to be booed
[Applause]
and i challenge those of you
i'm not making a comment on the fact
that there are people who transition
between sexes
so just stepping into it further and
further so there's a couple of different
things here first of all as usual
sex and gender
lummus is quite confused at the same
time it is a scientific truth that some
people are born intersex so
even though of course she's confused
between sex and gender
uh she also states wrongly
that it's a fundamental scientific truth
that there's male and female but in fact
i know it's a small percentage of people
but if if you want to bring up science
you kind of have to acknowledge that
she's also wrong on that but that's not
even really the issue
these commencement speeches the whole
idea is you bring a speaker who ideally
is going to be inspiring to the people
in the audience it is going to sort of
set up you're going to kind of wind them
up and send them off with energy and and
uh hope and ambition
to do things to improve the world
and instead she took the speech as an
opportunity
to do transphobic stuff
to do uh religious stuff as religion
should be part of government
talked about guns you saw her talk about
the second amendment this is just the
complete wrong place for it and
unfortunately the initial response from
the school president was pretty
mealy-mouthed the ini ed seidel or seidl
is the president of uw and initially put
out a statement saying on saturday the
university celebrated spring
commencement with a series of events
that showcased blah blah blah one of our
speakers made remarks regarding
biological sex that many on campus take
issue with
while we respect the right of all to
express their views from students to
election of elected officials we
unequivocally state that uw is an
institution that supports and celebrates
its diverse communities
that collectively make us the wonderful
place that we are
uh we welcome the incredible
individuality and intellect of all of
our dynamic and diverse students and
never want you to feel otherwise so not
really a criticism of the actual speaker
and then that statement after being
decried is not very good another
statement was point put out uh the
following day from the university which
was a little more clear and it said
unfortunately
during one of the ceremonies there was
reason for pause amid the celebration
and they name her they say wyoming
senator
cynthia lummus
offered the following statement they
quote the statement about two sexes our
faculty staff and students no that is
not the scientific truth
we affirm that humans may comprise
various chromosomal variations not every
person is strictly born female or male
intersex members of our community who
have diverse chromosomal makeup should
be seen and recognized now
that's also kind of a cop-out
only in the sense that
the reason
the lummis statement confuses sex and
gender anyway because she's confused
and they take the same approach i
initially took which is to say
even assuming she meant sex
she's wrong
really the issue here is a broader issue
about gender and transgender but it
doesn't matter it was good to see that
after being shamed university of wyoming
put out and listen
you don't always want to attack the
speakers that you invite i get it
uh but they said it and i'm glad to see
it but just what what a dumb speech i
don't know any other way to say it
hey uh i don't you if you know me you
know i love a good conspiracy theory i i
just i just really do um and one that is
really funny
is about reptilians now maybe you don't
know what reptilian is that like a
reptile well it's like a reptile human
sort of blend like a reptil reptile-like
humanoid
um
this comes from a number of different
places but where we most recently saw it
this is crazy eric balling is now a news
max host
newsmax is a a crazier version of fox
news eric balling actually used to be on
fox news now he wasn't like a serious
reporter i'm not going to say that but
he was on fox news he was ultimately
pushed out of fox news because of uh
sexual uh um harassment allegations
against him on newsmax he seriously
devoted a segment to maybe former
president barack obama was a reptilian
check this out back in 2013. look at
that you see that obama visited the
middle east and gave a speech an
ordinary speech but allegedly a
reptilian was identified in the crowd a
secret service agent with very unique
features
either way people ran with it and if you
can believe this they even created a
list on how to identify lizard people
interesting obama did have low blood
pressure he doesn't wear glasses he does
love science
that's right remember when he invited
that clock kid to the white house an
aspiring little scientist who made a
clock built it into a suitcase wires
hanging out all over with a countdown
all very alarming don't you think and he
submitted the project to school well the
worst thing could have happened the
suitcase started beeping people thought
it was a bomb the teacher called the
cops parents were upset it was all whole
ordeal but i bet if clock kid brought
that to the white house unannounced it
would ruffle some feathers now okay so
eric balling barely able to read off of
the teleprompter some people are saying
that he's not taking the conspiracy
theory seriously others are saying he
clearly is it kind of doesn't matter the
fact that they're even explaining uh
talking about these claims
in this way is absolutely bizarre so for
those who don't know i i really do love
this stuff
reptilian conspiracy theories um they're
sometimes they call them reptoids
reptiloids or lizard people these are
supposed reptilian humanoids and the
idea of reptilians goes back to david
icke david icke is a conspiracy theorist
who has claimed that shape-shifting
reptilian aliens control earth
because they take on a human form so
they pass as humans and then they use
their intelligence combined with their
fake human form to gain political power
and then they manipulate human societies
and icky has previously stated that
there are lots of world leaders either
who are reptilian or are possessed by or
controlled by reptilians and there are
adherents of the q anon conspiracy
theory
who borrow a lot of stuff from
reptilians you know with with all of
these things this is a particularly
funny one to me now i know that you can
say this one is
damaging in the sense that the people
that believe it often are also
anti-semitic they talk about uh you know
uh
globalists globalist yeah uh and all of
this stuff but by itself it's just kind
of dumb and of course we have to some at
some point apply an occam's razor to it
this just seems really complicated and
if they could take on
this human form
why would they do it in a way that they
would be identifiable like that infamous
video it's like a weird grainy angle of
some secret service agent that he was
talking about that's really old they've
brought that up before
why would they take such a reptilian
form if they have such advanced
technology and they're so smart
why couldn't they just design it so that
they look past like humans i mean none
of it makes sense but the fact that
newsmax is putting this stuff up as if
it's really a topic of discussion shows
us how far we've fallen it's even beyond
fox news i think although maybe not i'd
have to go back and review some of the
fox news segments eric balling from fox
news host
to sexual harassment claims
to getting fired
although officially they parted ways
amicably
to
spreading ideas about reptilians on
newsmax my how the mighty have fallen
remember that on monday memorial day we
will have a one day membership special
we can uh offer you this special
only on a holiday
because our entire team will be on break
so they won't know that we're kind of
giving away the farm with such a big
discount i would love for you to sign up
for a membership at joinpacman.com
but if you want the biggest discount
just get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com
monday memorial day you'll get an email
telling you exactly how to sign up
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show is of course a
community and audience supported program
you can sign up at joinpackman.com
and get instant access
not only to the bonus show oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad but also to the uh
daily commercial free audio stream daily
commercial free video stream and you get
all of it six hours before
everybody else
sign up at join joinpackman.com
let's speak to people people in the
audience we take calls via discord you
can go to davidpakman.com discord it's
all free i have nothing to sell you in
this particular case other than a good
time
let's start today with ricky from
charlotte ricky are you reveling in the
loss of madison cothorn in your state
you know i'm actually a little bit
uh upset i never liked him but
seeing like these videos come out that
kind of normalized him a little bit
i mean you know it's seeing like him in
like a more candid uh sort of uh
position and seeing that that's what
took him down i don't i really don't
like that is that what you feel is that
the discussion in north carolina that
it's the personal stuff that took him
down
uh yes without a doubt um you know that
people are like big you know uh decorum
ninjas and stuff like that here
yeah that definitely took him down
anyways but david you know i wanted to
ask you this and and i i want you to
answer this uh as as honest and candidly
as possible okay i recently kind of had
an epiphany
looking at
uh
kind of looking at how bad things uh are
right now and how bleak the future looks
and and this is about everything you
know it seems to me
like a lot of momentum is with the right
right now how strong and united they are
um the republican party is increasingly
going into an authoritarian fascist
direction yes uh on top of that the
problems that uh we have with uh this
war which i really don't like how it's
it seems to be escalating uh and the
fact that we we're still not addressing
big issues like climate change um
all of this like really does make me
feel uh kind of like what chomsky was
saying recently about how we're getting
like the doomsday clock is ticking so
assuming you like agree with a lot of
those sentiments is there anything in
spite of all this that gives you any
optimism or hope with all this going on
i mean it's it's sort of cliche at this
point but it's that
if you zoom out a little it does seem
that things are generally getting better
and i know that a lot of people it's
very unpopular now you know this is like
the steven pinks pinkster uh pinsker
thing
um oh wait is that his name i know i
don't know stephen yeah steven the the
whole thing of how uh over time you know
death from wars has gone down and infant
mortality has gone down and all of that
stuff it doesn't ignore that there's
many problems that we could have already
fixed like hunger for example but i
maintain just like a general cautious
optimism particularly
with the idea that young people are
actually motivated to find solutions to
a lot of these problems and so i i
maintain a long-term optimism
but i do think the next eight to ten
years could be pretty bad
yeah i
you know my my like the bar has gotten
so low for me like i honestly like i
don't care about who wins
the the the next couple of elections i
mainly just want one the us to still be
a democracy in ten years right that we
haven't the whole world hasn't been
destroyed in a nuclear war and that
there can still be something saved from
the planet that it will still be
inhabitable uh there's still something
we can do to make it still inhabitable
for like the next hundred years that's
just the main things that i want to
see happen i'm right with you ricky i'm
right with you there
yeah thank you all right thank you for
the call there's ricky from charlotte
let's go next to
oh i don't know why don't we go to chris
from texas chris you're on the air
hey david again nice to talk to you with
you again pleasure
all right so i guess one thing i'm just
kind of a little scared about is like
there's been just an increase in white
supremacist violence and rhetoric
throughout this whole country like we
saw in 2018 with the pittsburgh
synagogue shooting then we saw it again
in 2019 with the
el paso shooting in the pro-age signal
shooting and now just recently with this
buffalo shooting i just feel like we
have to do something about it i feel
like we have to take more measures like
against like the news media that's
responsible for like such as fox news
about these things
when you say we have to take action what
would you do to fox news
i feel like we need to i mean one thing
i'm thinking about doing
is we would probably need to maybe try
to pressure their sponsors to probably
cut off ties to people such as tucker
carlson because i feel like as long as
tucker carlson still gets money from fox
news and he brings in a lot of the money
since he's like the highest rating
person there there's not gonna be much
incentive for fox news to change well
what you have to remember we actually
talked about this earlier this week fox
is different than some of the other
networks in that fox gets two-thirds of
its revenue from subscription fees from
cable companies and uh not so much from
advertising so actually going after
fox's advertisers doesn't have as big of
an effect as it would on some other
companies that's
other channels which is an unfortunate
thing so really what people have to do
is you have to call your cable company
and say
i don't want fox news make fox an
optional channel and if i don't want it
i save my two bucks a month that would
actually crush fox
kind of like what we did with oan with
the whole
atp scandal that they had in a sense but
the difference is that fox is included
in just standard cable packages and
people don't even realize that close to
two dollars a month from what they pay
is going to fox even if you don't watch
it that has to come off
all right thank you very much for the
call sounds like we're having a bit of a
connection issue but yeah that's the
issue with going after fox's advertisers
they're not nearly as reliant on
advertisers as many of the other uh
platforms let's go next to johnny from
boston johnny welcome
hey david
um i have a question in regards to the
trans women in bathroom legislations
i've been going around and sure quite
frankly i don't feel like they really
are honest with the language because if
i feel like they're playing on
the
prejudices of voters and of maybe
ignorances of what trans people are do
you think that's done willingly or do
you think that they're people who really
don't understand what
like trans issues and trance rights are
well give me what do you what do you
mean what's the language that you that's
in the bills that you think doesn't
consider the reality of trans folks
so
they talk more about like though we're
going to have trans women in bathrooms
and then it's like we're going to go
you're going to only have the people in
the bathroom of their biological sex
assigned at birth however
they're not thinking of the reality is
that
that means trans men who look and
present as men are going to end up in
women's bathrooms if they go
right like they don't feel like they're
thinking this out you're absolutely
right and so what you're basically what
you're pointing out is that if you just
make a rule that basically says you've
got to go in the bathroom that matches
your biological sex at birth there are
plenty of trans women now who
they they to the av i'm trying to use
you know
careful but respectful language to the
average person you see these individuals
and you go that's a woman you you either
you would have no particular reason to
say that's not actually a woman as i see
it if they are forced to go to the men's
room
it's going to be just as confusing of a
situation you can also take take the
opposite uh and talk about trans men as
well so you're completely correct and
the issue is they don't really care
about that they just care about having
what they see
as the morally and politically correct
rule
um that goes along with their
pre-existing worldview they don't care
about the practicality or reality of it
yeah and it's and i and i also
am frustrated with people who are gops
who say that they're trans allies and
don't speak up
like that's that's hot garbage yeah they
should that like i see people like megan
mccain not say a damn thing about it but
oh is that right
yeah and she claims to be uh like an
lgbt ally you go you know t means trans
all right
platform a lot of people you know for
for a lot of people
being an lgbt ally means they have one
lesbian friend you know right or they
want to watch drag race like that's
literally
right very well said johnny thank you
yeah thanks that was it there's johnny
and boston great to hear from you as
always
let's go next to um
oh i don't know uh there's a lot a lot
of people a lot of interesting folks
waiting today why don't we go to
ruminate in kentucky is ruminate your
first or last name
it is just my stage name okay
david man i appreciate you taking the
call and you can you hear me well i can
hear you beautifully
perfect
so i'm a big fan of the show i was
introduced to you during the pandemic
okay and uh you and like brian tyler
cohen and a bunch of others you helped
get me through it so i appreciate you
know all that you do
i do have a specific question about
rhetoric moderating rhetoric so
you know friends of yours like destiny
who i'm also a fan of and even your new
correspondent uh luke beasley who did a
great job in texas um
they are fans of or they seem to be
proponents of
moderating rhetoric that leftists even
progressive leftists in terms of their
public outreach
should moderate their rhetoric
even though the gop seems to be
increasingly radical increasingly
aggressive
um and there's like this this um dispute
in the leftist community should we be
more aggressive should we try to appeal
more across the aisle and i'm curious
what you think about it well let me ask
what do you what why do you say that our
correspondent luke seems to favor
moderating rhetoric what gave you that
impression
he did uh a discussion with vosh or
vaush yesterday it was a really good
conversation oh luke beasley did
yeah yep how did they get in touch
that's fascinating i didn't know they
talked to each other i mean your name
carries weight man he's he's a d-pac
correspondent that's like that's
political royalty oh i'm gonna have to
watch that okay and so he said he was a
fan of of moderating rhetoric yeah
because i mean i'm sure you're familiar
enough with bosch to know that you know
which i'm a fan of his as well but he
definitely takes a more aggressive
route with respect to rhetoric he thinks
that the republican party as an
institution its leadership is evil
they're morally wicked and so he feels
that there should be
a greater condemnation of the gop by
leftists by democrats by progressive by
just bog standard liberals yep and
luke's position was broadly like hey man
i think that that's going to scare
people away
and i see both sides of it but i also
feel like this is the loop aired more
closely on the side of moderate rhetoric
is a moderate person and yet it doesn't
seem to be doing him any favors with
independence and centrists and whatnot
so that's why i wanted your take on i
mean you you in your videos you are very
candid that the republican party and the
democratic party
though flawed are not comparable the
democrat republicans are infinitely
worse as as a institution yeah do you
think that leftists
should be more emphatic about that like
no that this this notion of a bipartisan
you know future and that we need a
strong republican party like speaker
pelosi says that that's just crap and
we've got to get more radical in our
rhetoric so here's my view i don't think
that it should be one thing or the other
for contrived reasons of optics or
strategy i think that we should just be
really clear about calling things as i
see them so i can't speak for anybody
else's perspective my perspective is i'm
not going to artificially use milder or
more extreme rhetoric
just for the reason of how it will look
i'm going to describe things in the way
that i think they are and with the
language that i think is most
appropriate and when i'm talking about
radical repugnant lunatic trumpists
that's right what i'll call them i won't
say anything that's moderate more
moderate or more extreme than than what
i see them as being i'm open to other
people saying no the strategy should be
to use either more moderate or radical
rhetoric for this reason or for that
reason my approach and people can tell
me it doesn't work or it's wrong is i i
just call things and describe things as
they are with the language that feels
accurate
right
fair enough and then one last thing i
just want to say i think that you are
you're probably your standout quality on
your shows you are a superb interviewer
so i was going back and watching your
interviews with tim poole and michael
knowles and sam harris in that recent
one trigonometry um i guess my last
question is do you
do right wingers or more centrist
figures like sam harris isn't a right
winger but he is certainly more centrist
i think sure than many others do they
avoid
uh interviews with you or or like do you
reach out to people often to have those
sorts of incisive q's and a's and do
they do they take you up on the offer
it's a mix we reach out to tons of
people all the time and there's no rule
you know sam harris has previously
accepted requests from us but for a year
and a half i've been trying to get him
back on and he is not accepted so i i
there's no hard and fast rule but i'm
obviously open to talking to all sorts
of people
yeah well i appreciate it david thanks
and keep doing what you're doing man
thank you so much appreciate the call
i'm gonna have to check out that vouch
and luke beasley appearance that sounds
pretty interesting
let's see where we want to go next
oh i don't know
um what about maybe
dave from kansas city dave you're on the
air
can you hear me yes i can
alrighty then uh first time caller um
i'm going to be as brief as i can it is
kind of a loaded question um
basically my politics lean the same as
you
so there's no um head-to-head here if
you will uh but i've not been keeping
the best update on the situation this is
regarding the supreme court leak okay um
basically
you said something recently that kind of
made me raise an eyebrow and i've seen
other people do it as well
so here we go um initially it was stated
by those on the right that the left-wing
person did it
to try to pressure change from the
leaked opinion yep um but later i heard
that uh the reddit the rhetoric changed
um to the likely
a person on the right putting pressure
on the judges to keep their vote the
reason this raised an eyebrow for me was
because
you know if you assume the least
amount of information out of all these
using occam's razor these are the same
amount of assumptions
what am i missing from the quote-unquote
likely yeah nature
that's a great question so basically in
terms of plausibility
when it comes to the supreme court leak
you can argue in if if you know nothing
and you all you have is motive you could
say well a left winger would have motive
to leak it to try to pressure the
justices who were going to vote to
overturn roe v wade to change their mind
from motive you could also say a right
winger might have leaked it in order to
try to pressure the justices planning to
overturn roe v wade to stick with that
decision if they suspected maybe they
were going to change so that you're
absolutely right we don't have more
information one way or the other
we have gotten reports from long-time
supreme court reporters including one
from npr whose name i don't remember
offhand who said
based on everyone she's talked to
the consensus within the court is that
it was more likely a right winger so
that's that's the only difference maker
you're correct that we have almost the
same thing on both sides other than a
couple of reports from long-time supreme
court reporters who say the feeling is
it was more likely a right winger we
don't know at this point
okay
yeah it was just something that kind of
i didn't hear that last part the i think
maybe now that i'm thinking about it i
just couldn't find it going through i
only have so much time to go through all
the videos yeah we linked to the source
in the story i did about it we linked to
the npr source
okay sounds good i'll check that out all
right thank you so much for the call we
are going to take more calls in a moment
i'm just going to take a very quick
break and then we'll be right back just
hold on and then we'll get to more
people
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com david pakman show let's go
back uh to discord at davidpakman.com
discord and speak to some more people we
use what's called the waiting lobby when
we take calls
why don't we speak to
uh there's really a lot of people today
who want to chat but we want to try to
get to some
a wide representation let's go to brenda
from minnesota brenda you're on the air
um hello david this is brenda from
minnesota how are you doing today i'm
doing well thank you
uh i called specifically because i i
don't know if you're familiar with him
uh telltale
uh who is owen has he has a several web
uh youtube channels called telltale
telltale atheist
and stuff and he published a video
recently that gives specific
instructions to women on how to get an
abortion specifically for women who
happen to be
in a state which may you know
prevent prevent them getting an abortion
specific instructions on exactly who who
to
um
email and how to how to get um
abortion pills um and it is um
okay hold on brenda i've got to
interrupt you so
this this is a bit precarious only
because
i don't know who this person is
i don't know what their credentials are
i'm not up to speed on the legality of
quote getting abortion pills and all of
the different legal infrastructure i
just want to be really careful about
what we put out here because i don't
want to overstep or create a problem of
any kind for anyone including myself so
i don't know i mean listen it's great
that there are resources out there for
people but let's maybe ease up a little
on the specifics here if we can
oh okay so it is legal um because
which part is legal
it is legal to receive uh
abortion pills through the mail this was
a very recent thing
but now correct me if i'm wrong but
isn't it that's legal in states where
it is already legal to obtain them right
i mean that so so based on the existing
legal infrastructure getting them
through the mail is okay
my understanding it's legal everywhere
in the united states okay see that
wasn't my understanding so
are you a lawyer by chance
uh no i i'm a nobody i'm not either so
let's just let's just be careful but so
you you want people to look up telltale
is that right
i posted a link in the chat here um he
has a video and if you talk to him you
know maybe your concerns would be
addressed more uh he would be a good
guest but also this information i think
it'd be good to uh amplify this this
information it's um if you if you hosted
it he said that he will not um you know
he's not copyrighted or
do any damn strikes but maybe if you
talk to him maybe if you talk to him
more he can be more specific on the
legalities
good okay that sounds good thank you
brenda
yeah you're welcome all right there's
brenda from minnesota we we just we
don't want to do anything wrong on the
show you know that's the that's the
priority uh we want to be we want to be
very careful
let's go next to
uh let's go to nick from long island
nick welcome
hey david um so
my question is is um
do you think that
so we had primaries last night we had
john fetterman win the pennsylvania
primary
and um it's looking like conservative
democrat kurt schrader is going to lose
his primary to a more left-leaning
candidate
i was wondering because i've heard many
on the left say that progressive
candidates have a better chance of
winning the general election
do you agree with that or do you think
that more moderate candidates have
better chances of winning there's no one
answer for that so for example
in west virginia
if a more progressive democrat manages
to successfully primary joe manchin
that progressive democrat almost
certainly loses the election in west
virginia and we get a republican senator
in a place like pennsylvania i think a
more progressive democrat
is far more likely to do well in the
general so there's no one answer what in
order to say
who is likely to do better you first
have to answer the question well who's
in the electorate are we talking about
nationally are we talking about a
particular congressional district or a
state does that make sense
yeah um well doesn't it like depend on
what policies are popular in the state
we're talking about that's right it does
so so to say
are progressives likely to do better
the question is well who are the voters
and what do they want
yeah um
so it's not like it's not like a black
and white thing no not at all not at all
there are there are there are seats
where
a centrist democrat
is as left as would be able to win
there are other seats like for example
aoc's district aoc replaced a longtime
incumbent she was she's well to his left
because the electorate lined up with her
views does you know what i'm saying
yeah but that's that's like a safe seat
that's a safe democratic seat i'm
talking about like in mainly swing uh
swing districts well it depends on the
specifics of the district is what i'm
saying yeah
um all right
um yeah and i wanted to point that out
because i heard uh
from dave wasserman on twitter saying
that the cook political report will
change oregon's fifth district to a
toss-up race if
kurt schrader loses his primary to a
more i forgot the
person's name but yeah okay
all right um
all right thank you okay thank you very
much i appreciate the call yeah not one
answer that's a it's a great question
it's a complicated question as well
uh why don't we speak next to
um
let's go to i hope i pronounced this
correctly is it saki kazi from pakistan
uh yeah no
sorry uh
no i said [ __ ] your name but that's all
right
all right well welcome to the show
uh yeah dude i'm a big fan of your show
i've been watching your videos on
youtube and they're really um
interesting and
they pique my interest thank you
oh
sorry i'm a little uh
giddy here i guess or something you're
doing great what what's your question
what's on your mind
i was just thinking the um
i'm i don't know i don't know if this is
uh
relevant right now or something but i
feel like
if you had the chance
to say um
get
i would say this i i don't know they may
be controversial or not but if you were
to get say the former president on your
show
you're talking about trump
no boy
yeah your connections your connections
gone into the toilet
sorry i'm gonna have to flush the
connection 10 to 15 times we just we're
just losing you it's uh it's just
digital noises i i apologize
let's go to kyle from south carolina
kyle welcome
kyle from south carolina you're on the
show
and last chance for kyle from south
carolina you've got to unmute
now i can
hi how's it going
good
um the reason why i was falling is
because uh i've been recently rescued on
uh represent us have you heard anything
about it kyle i'm sorry are you using
speakerphone or something you sound like
you're underwater
uh i'm using uh my earbud a recon earbud
i changed the straight headphone then
okay your question was about
representation
dear god all right we're gonna have to
move on everything going wrong this was
going so well for so long
let's try matthew from jersey matthew
please save us
hello oh my god you're not running a
lathe in the background are you
i
do you need any do you need me to do
something then
yes please run a lathe no i'm kidding go
ahead what's what's going on what's on
your mind today
well
one thing of course um
that i've been thinking about um
is now obviously this has changed a
little bit with last night's primaries
because a lot of left-wing people like
won their summer league john fetterman
charles booker i think there was a few
in oregon
but what i was going to say was thinking
about beforehand was
you had you know similar to how you said
like you know trump's momentum that was
so big
and it um
then it starts to go away thank goodness
hawthorne's gone
um
and so
it made me think you know it's like so
many of what uh
let me think of bernie who i like a lot
but you know like his um his big number
one spokesman turner the the symbol of
the left-wing movement she ran she ran
she she ran for congress the first time
almost almost won close call did so she
runs the second time gets obliterated
and it makes me think
is the bernie factor also
losing its luster and furthermore since
bernie was never president and was it
ever really there to begin with
that's a fair question i mean i've said
before as a bernie supporter i
recognized that the perception of
bernie's level of support was pretty
significantly overstated if you spent a
lot of time on twitter and reddit
relative to the democratic party at
large
um i don't know that i would say that
that bernie's uh bernie's losing his
luster i mean i think
bernie's not been a major factor in the
last year i think is what i say matthew
i have to ask what is all that noise in
the background
you i don't i don't hear any noise it
sounds like either a didgeridoo or a
lawn mower i'm going to answer the rest
of the of the question offline just just
so we don't um
uh subject our audience to the to the
torture there um i think what's going on
is that some of these races nina turner
i think is a good example and i know
people get really mad when i make this
analysis
the electorate
in that district
i forget what number district in ohio
is just not as left
as maybe it seemed from the national
enthusiasm behind nina turner it's not
an insult it's not an attack it's just
the recognition that the people that
voted didn't really seem to be
buying
the nina turner
uh ideology which she was selling and we
just have to recognize it kind of goes
back to the earlier question of
it is a progressive more likely to win
well where in what district in what
state and when when
um and so i think that there's no one
answer to that question but it's less
about
bernie's momentum or whatever it's you
know there are there are places where
the voters they maybe they're wrong
maybe they're ignorant
but
they prefer
something different than bernie nina
turner and we all have to just kind of
recognize that and meet people where
where they are at least initially um
and then then you see what changes you
can make
let's go to um
[Music]
matt the social studies guy welcome matt
what's going on
hey david um so i wanted to ask are you
familiar with um jamie raskin had
mentioned um
oh this is a few weeks back now he had
mentioned that there's going to be
public hearings of information uncovered
uh starting next month i believe it is
yeah january 9th the january 6th
committee i'm sorry june 9th the january
6th committee hearing start
okay um and i i also want to know i
believe his quote he used was uh you
know the the things that are going to
come to light you know paraphrasing but
they're going to blow the roof off the
house and now my my question is
i think it's a great idea um and i i
would think you would agree you know we
all kind of want to know what has been
uncovered we want to know you know the
nuts and bolts of what happened yeah
um and i know there's a good portion of
us probably all the left i don't want to
overstate that also want to know what's
going on
i also know that there's a a contingent
on the right who
right out of the gate they're just going
to say you know it's a partisan witch
hunt it's garbage it's fake news
you know what have you they're not going
to listen whatever is said
so my my question is
you know do you do you think there's a
portion of people on the fence who are
going to be swayed by this you know how
how effective you think it's going to be
and actually kind of getting people to
see
you know
what really went on here i think that
the effect of the january 6th hearings
if they are what jamie raskin says
they're going to be
is going to be less about changing minds
but more about activating people because
remember we have very low voter turnout
in this country especially in midterms
so my optimistic hope would be and
there's no guarantee that this happens
if people who don't normally vote here
in those hearings about the terrible
things that were done in trying to steal
the election and the lead up to the
trump riots that they will say you know
what i don't normally vote but this time
i'm going to so in my mind it's more
about activating people than it is about
changing minds
i see very good thank you all right
thank you for the call matt the social
studies guy that's going to do it for
calls today we will take a quick break
and be back with much more right after
this
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
it is the world famous friday mailbag if
you have anything you want to say to me
say it you can email info
davidpakman.com don't abuse it if you
send emails regularly you've probably
been flagged and filtered right into the
trash unfortunately there are people who
send us dozens of emails a day even five
a day
we just can't we just can't handle it we
have too many too many emails coming in
um uh if you're if you're abusing it
unfortunately it's getting filtered my
friends but let's get into some of the
messages that we did get brian wrote in
about an inaccuracy in a video
david your recent video confidence in
trump filled supreme court collapses has
an inaccuracy chief justice roberts took
the bench on september 29 2005.
this was after the re-election of bush
where he did win the popular vote
against kerry by approximately 3 million
votes the same can be said about justice
alito
going on to say who assumed the bench in
2006. while i understand what you're
saying about the 2000 popular vote count
the claim you made is partial partially
inaccurate and requires
further context yes so the my point was
had bush had the first election
gone by the popular vote
bush never would have been president and
so yes this is true that there was
another election which bush did win but
which bush never would have been in the
position of being reelected
had it not been for the electoral rather
than popular vote results in the year
2000.
next email is from marco suggestion for
one and a half million subscribers
marco says i know you're going to reach
that milestone quite strongly
as an act of powerful celebration i
think you should shave your head when
you reach that goal
yeah like i honestly i would be willing
to do that when we get to 1.5 million
subscribers
but not just because we get there like
we'll get there eventually the question
is is there anything we can do to get
there much more quickly
and i don't know that promising to shave
my head is actually going to do it
one other uh idea that came in from
maurice was david on achieving 1.5
million subscribers subscribers may i
suggest you do a live colonoscopy on air
now what's funny about that is
in general when we say doing a
colonoscopy we mean the doctor does it
the patient receives it so i'm going to
guess maurice thinks i should receive a
colonoscopy on air
but what he's actually saying is i
should perform one and
my specialty is podiatry i could not
possibly do a colonoscopy that would be
outside
of my area of expertise but
it's an interesting idea nonetheless
there the audience must be very
confident
in me to suggest that
ryan wrote in about 2 000 mules and says
david do you plan on watching or
commenting on dinesh d'souza's 2000
mules my right wing co-workers have been
talking about it and i'm looking forward
to you dismantling the claims made in
the film
ryan
has actually been leaving dozens of
youtube comments saying the same thing
ryan's obsessed with the film so i
watched the sub the quote substantive to
the first two thirds of the film
it's nonsense
there there's really nothing to refute
the whole concept of the film is that
using cell phone uh
locate geolocation data
which is not that accurate they pretend
it's accurate accurate and extrapolate
from that
that there were people
trafficking massive dumps of ballots
illegally
on election day in 2020.
there's there's no actual evidence
presented it's worthless don't waste
your time it'll it'll really rot your
brain
um so no we are not going to be we are
not going to be talking too much more
about that
um next my pronunciation of bangor maine
sabrina from ellsworth maine wrote in
and said
there's no er it's or i i pronounce that
banger
and sabrina says it's bangor
i actually you know 99
of the time my mispronunciations on this
show are purposeful you know dan bongino
tulsi gabbard
etc
i i actually didn't remember how to
pronounce bangor i thought it might have
been banger
i apologize to anyone who was offended
thank you sabrina
douglas wrote in and says argument for
prosecuting out-of-state abortions could
states that want to prosecute its
citizens for out-of-state abortions try
to argue that it's the same as if
california made murder legal and someone
took their child to california murdered
the child and then came back to their
home state well
you could argue that but
generally speaking states can only
prosecute crimes committed in their
jurisdiction
in their jurisdiction so
if murder were legal in california
generally speaking if you take your kid
to california and kill them where it's
legal and then you go back to wherever
nebraska where it's illegal
nebraska can't prosecute you for a crime
that happened outside of its
jurisdiction so it's an interesting
question
it just doesn't work the way i think
douglas you may think it does
it's also kind of it's a very depressing
example i should say
um
catherine wrote in is miscarriage
manslaughter then david if fetuses have
rights then doesn't it follow that they
have rights to due process
it would be incredibly evil but any
miscarriage ought to be investigated on
the behalf of the miscarried fetus did
would-be mama miss her vitamins did she
travel against doctor's advice did
would-be papa slam on the brakes while
speeding causing mama seat belt trauma
most miscarriages can in many cases be
shown to be a parent legally at fault if
the fetus has a right to life and due
process in the case of death incredibly
evil
but it's exactly what they're arguing
for isn't it catherine in in many cases
in many senses it is
in many senses it is and
listen we played a clip on our monday
show from someone that luke beasley
interviewed at the trump event over the
weekend who said mothers who get an
abortion should get the death penalty
they they believe
uh abortion is murder
the mother is the murderer
in texas they have the death penalty so
that's it murder you know put put to
death the mother and unfortunately
these are exactly the types of things i
mean listen last week we played a clip
about right-wingers expecting to start
to see
uh the death penalty for abortion
providers as well so that's exactly what
they're pointing to and it's quite
horrifying
next email is from christopher
christopher says
you are unapologetically using the tools
you decry
david many of us are aware you're
employing the slippery slope in your row
coverage and yet some two months ago you
exposed the slippery slope for what it
is a fallacy here's a link to that video
for reference what's up with that chris
the fallacy
is
wrongly talking about a slippery slope
in the same way that appeal to authority
isn't a fallacy if we're actually
dealing with an authority in the subject
matter
the fact that the slippery slope fallacy
exists doesn't make it fallacious when
it's accurate and within days of the
leaked roe v wade ruling you had
all sorts of anti-choice activists
talking about we've got to start
prosecuting the moms and we've got to
prosecute the abortion doctors
greg abbott in texas saying we've got to
reverse the supreme court decision that
allows the children of undocumented
immigrants to go to public school they
want to do away with that because listen
if you can do away roe v wade you can do
away with that
they're again talking about gay marriage
and saying gay marriage was just as
wrongly decided uh
we
there we've now had a dozen examples so
the slippery slope is not a fallacy when
it's happening
when it's happening and it is already
a user named truth and more truth
wrote on youtube i just don't get how
someone like alex jones has any
supporters how who is this stupid wwe
actors are more believable he admitted
it's all an act in court he could be
wearing a shirt that says i'm fake i'm
using you you're stupid if you believe
me
and people will still follow him that's
absolutely true
that's and we see that with a lot of the
trump-ist type cult
where it's
they could they could just lie
i'm sorry they could tell the truth
exposing that it's all a grift
and they would still have followers and
you know how they would rationalize it
they would go
alex jones had to say that in court
he's not really playing a character he
had to say it in court because otherwise
they were going to get him but he really
believes the stuff he says now i don't
actually know
alex jones may well believe the things
he said i've gone back and forth over
the years about
which it is
brian wrote in about me
this loser is still on youtube this
channel is trash
david pakman has an iq of a tennis ball
but that would be an insult to the ball
itself your channel sucks david pakman
sucks he doesn't covered anything
realistic this show is all bs all day
every day just like david pakman face is
and then i think that's the vomit emoji
brian remember
you don't have to watch this show it's
optional
it's optional you don't have to be here
my recommendation continues to be
if you don't like the show
don't watch the show i know it's a novel
thing and also by the way
you don't have to comment about
everything i say
like you don't have to email me
because i said something you disagree
with you could just go
oh yeah i disagree with that
i'm gonna get back to work or whatever
the case may be it's an option it's an
option it is available to you we have a
great bonus show for you today sign up
at joinpacman.com speaking of alex jones
jones would tell you not to get the
bonus show oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to find themselves is bad he
doesn't like it but i do and so i
encourage you to sign up at
joinpacman.com
get the bonus show we'll see you then